Hey guys, it's Sean and it's getting hot out, so I'm going to make some lemonade and do some hats that I'm going to be selling. So if you want to block your face from the sun or somebody you don't like, come on down and buy a hat. Welcome to Smart List. Jason came over the other day on Sunday to watch little football and he brought young Maple with him to hang with the boys. First thing he does, every time he comes over, he goes straight to my fridge and then to my pantry to walk me through to shame me for whatever food I've got in the house. A lot of material.
嘿，伙计们，我是肖恩。外面天气越来越热了，所以我打算做点柠檬水，还要做些帽子拿去卖。所以如果你想遮挡阳光，或者想挡住某个你不喜欢的人，那就过来买顶帽子吧。欢迎收听《Smart List》。杰森前几天周日过来，我们一起看了会儿橄榄球，他还带了小梅普尔来和孩子们一起玩。他每次过来做的第一件事，就是直奔我的冰箱，然后去储藏室，带我走一圈，羞辱我家里存的那些食物。素材可真多啊。
But then so much of it, it's dripping with jealousy. He's trying to shame me for my food. How about the three pizza boxes that were in the pantry? There's only you and two young boys that live in that house. There were three large pizzas, one of which, thank God, wasn't even eaten the following day. Just sitting there on the countertop. Well, first of all, we have more than that. We have, there are at various times four boys in this house, A. And B, we like to try different pizza and then we eat it over the course of days and we put it in the fridge and we have pizza one day a week. So you're not polluting them with just one dinner of pizza. You spread it out over a
但其中大部分内容，都充满了嫉妒。他试图因为我的食物而羞辱我。那储藏室里的三个披萨盒怎么说？那房子里只有你和两个小男孩住。有三个大披萨，谢天谢地，其中一个第二天甚至都没吃。就那么放在台面上。好吧，首先，我们不止有那些。我们有，这房子里有时会有四个男孩，A。而且B，我们喜欢尝试不同的披萨，然后分几天吃完，我们会把它放进冰箱，每周吃一次披萨。所以你并没有只用一顿披萨晚餐来毒害他们。你是把它分散在
full week and then there's two different kinds of Oreos that I eat cold. Those Oreos have been in there for six months. That sounds like my house. Nobody eats them. I never have. And there's all kinds of different honey toasted oats and Lucky Charms. And there was one dusty bag of unopened granola that I went ahead and enjoyed. I'm waiting to hear what the problem is. I know. So listen to this. Yeah. Well, no, yeah. So Sean and I were... You're hearing the problem is talking right now.
整整一周里，还有两种我冷着吃的奥利奥。那些奥利奥已经在那里放了六个月了。听起来像我家。没人吃它们。我从来没吃过。还有各种各样的蜂蜜烤燕麦和幸运符麦片。还有一个满是灰尘的未开封的格兰诺拉麦片袋，我直接拿来享用了。我等着听问题出在哪儿呢。我知道。所以听着。是啊。好吧，不，是啊。所以肖恩和我当时……你现在听到的就是问题所在。
So Sean, you, by the way, we go over to a very nice respectable couple for dinner the other night. Okay. Well, you were there too. Yes. He wants a beverage with his dinner like most normal people. He goes looking in the fridge for one. There's all kinds of healthy drinks in there, some carbonated flavored soda-ish things. Not good enough for Sean and his titanium, you know, stomach. Nope. He wants a pure Coca-Cola.
所以肖恩，顺便说一下，前几天晚上我们去一对非常体面、受人尊敬的夫妇家吃晚饭。好吧。嗯，你也在那儿。是的。他像大多数正常人一样，晚餐时想喝点饮料。他去冰箱里找。里面有各种健康的饮料，还有一些碳酸风味的苏打水之类的东西。这对肖恩和他那钛合金般的胃来说还不够好。不。他想要纯可口可乐。
That's right. And starts, he's opening up all kinds of cabinets and drawers and everything wondering, where's the Coke? Yeah. Like what's wrong with this house? One soft drink. I was looking for any soft drink. Soft drink is fine. And look, Richard went, it's our friend, Richard, who's a big listener on the program, and we love him to death.
没错。然后开始，他打开各种橱柜和抽屉，什么都翻，想知道，可乐在哪儿？是啊。就像这房子怎么了？一种软饮。我在找任何软饮。软饮就行。听着，理查德去了，那是我们的朋友理查德，他是节目的忠实听众，我们爱死他了。
We love him to death. Love him. So Richard went out of his way to find us drinks, et cetera. But again, the person who's the most upset about it is you, JB. Yeah. What's your relationship? Let's talk about that. Because you have such a knee-jerk reaction when it comes to talking about food and this kind of thing. Let's get into it a little bit.
我们爱死他了。爱他。所以理查德特意为我们找了饮料等等。但再说一次，对此最不高兴的人是你，JB。是啊。你们是什么关系？我们谈谈这个吧。因为你在谈论食物和这类事情时，反应总是那么过激。我们深入探讨一下吧。
Well, I was deprived of sugar, complex sugars, and most carbohydrates growing out. And do you love them? And I love them. Do you love them? I do love them, but my body loves them more. And so I have to, you know, keep them away from my body. Because as I've said multiple times, there's a 600-pound being just waiting to get out inside me. Our surprise guest has a fluffy cover over their camera.
嗯，我从小就被剥夺了糖分、复合糖和大多数碳水化合物。你喜欢它们吗？我喜欢它们。你喜欢它们吗？我确实喜欢，但我的身体更喜欢它们。所以我必须，你知道，让它们远离我的身体。因为正如我多次说过的，我体内有一个600磅重的家伙正等着出来。我们的惊喜嘉宾的摄像头上有一个毛茸茸的盖子。
Our surprise guest, they cover themselves with cashmere. Wow. Nice. This is a person who we all adore. I adore. This is somebody who's universally adored. I don't, you'd be pretty hard-pressed to find somebody who didn't have incredible things to say about this person. First of all, as a person, then as a performer, then just in every single way, this person, to me, epitomizes a great parent. They are a great performer. They are a great friend.
我们的惊喜嘉宾，他们用羊绒把自己盖住了。哇。不错。这是一个我们所有人都崇拜的人。我崇拜。这是一个普遍受到崇拜的人。我不知道，你很难找到一个对这个人没有极高评价的人。首先，作为一个人，然后作为一名表演者，然后从每一个方面来看，这个人，对我来说，是伟大父母的缩影。他们是一位伟大的表演者。他们是一位伟大的朋友。
In fact, you can almost say that this person is one of America's best friends. This person is no one other... This is a friend-friend? ...than Courtney Cox. Courtney. Courtney. Courtney. Courtney.
事实上，你几乎可以说这个人是美国最好的朋友之一。这个人不是别人……这是朋友中的朋友？……就是柯特妮·考克斯。柯特妮。柯特妮。柯特妮。柯特妮。
Review yourself. Review yourself. Courtney. Hi, Courtney. Now, why is it taking so long? I feel like we have tried this... Well, we've had a few booking snafus with Courtney. She's been elusive a little bit. Like a little kitty cat. I just feel weird since I know you guys so well, but I don't know. Probably because maybe
审视你自己。审视你自己。柯特妮。嗨，柯特妮。现在，为什么花了这么长时间？我觉得我们已经尝试过……嗯，我们和柯特妮在预约上出了一些小差错。她有点难以捉摸。像只小猫咪。我只是觉得很奇怪，因为我非常了解你们，但我不知道。可能是因为也许
we're just waiting to have something to talk about, or I don't know. It's kind of crazy though. What haven't we talked about? Because, listen, we all do gather at least once a week. Usually that's Courtney's fault, because she's so generous with her house and her time and her food. Without her, I think the glue would separate. Courtney, so you... Take your time. Take your time, Will. No, I'm trying to think where to start. You've done so many awesome things, and people will
我们只是在等有什么可聊的，或者我不知道。但这有点疯狂。我们还有什么没聊过的吗？因为，听着，我们确实至少每周聚一次。通常那是柯特妮的功劳，因为她对她的房子、她的时间和她的食物都非常慷慨。没有她，我想这胶水就会散开。柯特妮，所以你……慢慢来。慢慢来，威尔。不，我在想从哪儿开始。你做了这么多很棒的事情，人们会
know you from so many incredible things. Obviously, friends is just a worldwide sensation, the likes of which... Don't say, I don't.... The likes of which I've never been seen... God damn it, let him have his little phrases. But, you know, you've been part of our consciousness, sort of our cultural consciousness for a long time. For me, the thing that sticks out the most,
从这么多不可思议的事情中认识你。显然，《老友记》是一个全球性的轰动，那种……别说，我不要……那种前所未见……该死的，让他用他那些小短语吧。但是，你知道，你一直是我们意识的一部分，某种程度上是我们文化意识的一部分，已经很久了。对我来说，最突出的事情，
and this is one of my favorites, obviously, is Bruce Springsteen's Dancing in the Dark video, which we've talked about. And in fact, if you remember- But there's a bunch of people that listen to this that are younger than us that have no idea. No idea, so Bruce Springsteen had, when he had his- 1984 huge hit and Dancing in the Dark.
这是我的最爱之一，显然，是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的《Dancing in the Dark》MV，我们聊过这个。事实上，如果你记得——但有很多听这个节目的人比我们年轻，他们根本不知道。根本不知道，所以布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀当时，当他有——1984年的巨大热门歌曲和《Dancing in the Dark》。
Born in the USA. Born in the, off the Born in the USA record. And in the video, Bruce is playing, and then he singles a girl out from the audience, and it's Courtney, and he brings her on stage, and they dance, and they do this iconic dance. And it's so great. Where was that, the Coliseum?
《Born in the USA》。出自《Born in the USA》这张唱片。在MV里，布鲁斯在演奏，然后他从观众中挑出一个女孩，那是柯特妮，他把她带上舞台，他们跳舞，他们跳了这段标志性的舞蹈。太棒了。那是在哪儿，体育馆吗？
Yeah, it was, I think, in St. Paul. Oh, Minnesota, gotcha, okay. So Courtney, I don't know if you remember, so we were all on, remember we went on, we all went on vacation a few years ago with all the kids and everybody. And then I was in the gym, and you, I saw you coming, so I put on Dancing in the Dark.
是的，我想是在圣保罗。哦，明尼苏达，明白了，好的。所以柯特妮，我不知道你记不记得，我们当时都在，记得几年前我们和所有的孩子还有大家一起去度假吗。然后我在健身房，你，我看到你过来了，所以我放了《Dancing in the Dark》。
And then we danced, do you remember? Oh, Jesus. And that was an iconic moment. But that, for me, I know, is so good. But I loved, that was when we first, I think like America first, like you became, and then you have been part of our collection, you've been part of, a huge part of the cultural fabric
然后我们跳了舞，你记得吗？哦，天哪。那是一个标志性的时刻。但那，对我来说，我知道，太棒了。但我喜欢，那是我们第一次，我想就像美国第一次，就像你成为了，然后你一直是我们的收藏的一部分，你一直是，巨大的文化结构的一部分
since then, which is a long time. It is a long time. And what was that experience like for you? Was it, was that because music videos were so huge at that time? Yeah, that was when MTV first started, I think. Yeah, you know, I auditioned for that just like any other commercial,
从那时起，已经很长时间了。确实是很长时间了。那次经历对你来说是什么样的？是因为当时音乐录影带非常火吗？是啊，我想那是MTV刚开始的时候。是啊，你知道，我试镜那个就像试镜其他任何广告一样，
and Brian De Palma directed it. He asked me to come into the room, not, this is not a weird thing, but all the people came into his office and we danced. Wow. And everyone, I walked into the room, everyone, these dancers were stretching, and I was like, oh no, I'm in the wrong place.
布莱恩·德·帕尔玛导演的。他让我进房间，不，这不是什么奇怪的事，但所有人都进了他的办公室，我们跳了舞。哇。每个人，我走进房间，每个人，这些舞者在拉伸，我就想，哦不，我走错地方了。
I'm not a ballerina, or I didn't know what was gonna happen. And so he said, well, you dance. And I probably was the same reaction that I got when he pulled me up on stage. I was completely nervous, even though I liked to dance. It, I was so uncomfortable. And then when I got to St. Paul, I just remember him, Brian De Palma had the flu,
我不是芭蕾舞演员，或者我不知道会发生什么。所以他说，好吧，你跳舞吧。我当时的反应可能和他把我拉上舞台时一样。我完全紧张，尽管我喜欢跳舞。它，我太不自在了。然后当我到了圣保罗，我只记得他，布莱恩·德·帕尔玛得了流感，
so did Bruce Bingstein. It was his first night of tour, the first night he met, I'm not met, but sang with Patty Scaffa. Is that her name, Patty, say it? On stage. And there were three girls that were hired. And so when Brian said, okay,
布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀也得了。那是他巡演的第一晚，他第一次见到，不是见到，而是和帕蒂·斯卡尔法一起唱歌。是那个名字吗，帕蒂，说出来？在舞台上。有三个女孩被雇佣了。所以当布莱恩说，好吧，
so when Courtney goes on stage, and I was like, no, no, no, there's three of us. I do not wanna go on stage. Anybody else? She can, or she can't? I do not want to, and of course, that's probably the reason why they chose me. So when you auditioned and he said,
所以当柯特妮上台时，我就说，不，不，不，我们有三个人。我不想上台。还有别人吗？她可以，或者她不行？我不想，当然，这可能就是他们选择我的原因。所以当你试镜时，他说，
dance in my office, was it to that song? And were you dancing by yourself, or with him, Brian De Palma? No, I wish he'd stood up and danced. No, it was just me. By yourself, right? And it's my memory, right, that the iconic dance move that you were doing
在我的办公室里跳舞，是那首歌吗？你是自己跳，还是和他，布莱恩·德·帕尔玛一起跳？不，我希望他站起来跳。不，只有我。你自己，对吧？我的记忆没错吧，你跳的那个标志性的舞蹈动作
is very similar to, I wanna say, Matthew Perry's dance move in the Friends Opening thing. Jason, have you seen Matthew dance in the opening? I was copying Bruce. Matthew, no offense. I hope he's listening, not listening. He, please watch it again. That's not.
和马修·派瑞在《老友记》片头里的舞蹈动作非常相似？杰森，你看过马修在片头跳舞吗？我在模仿布鲁斯。马修，别介意。我希望他在听，没在听。他，请再看一遍。那不是。
But one of you dances in the same way, maybe? Or no, my memory is as bad as it was. It was very Miley Ringwald. Matt LeBlanc, maybe Matt LeBlanc does it. Well, I know that Schwimmer is really good. No, no, he does like a slow motion one or something, right? Or no, that's Schwimmer. Oh, yeah, Schwimmer does.
但你们中有人跳得一样，也许？或者不，我的记忆和以前一样差。那非常像莫莉·林沃德。马特·勒布朗，也许马特·勒布朗跳过。嗯，我知道施维默真的很棒。不，不，他做那种慢动作之类的，对吧？或者不，那是施维默。哦，是的，施维默确实。
He does that kind of slow motion walk, and Bob's his head, and I think the girls, Lisa does her head shake thing, has one arm up. She's, they're all. So no one does the Bruce Springsteen dance in the opening. No, I was copying Bruce Springsteen. At one point, he does a turn all the way around, I think. And I thought, okay, I'm gonna just do this.
他做那种慢动作行走，点头，我想女孩们，丽莎做她的摇头动作，一只手举起来。她，她们都是。所以没人做布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的舞蹈在片头。不，我在模仿布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。有一次，他转了一整圈，我想。我想，好吧，我就做这个。
And I started going for the turn. I thought, no, you can't do this. And a turn back, I was too scared. Did you, but that was in front of a live crowd. Did you have to do multiple takes, or was it like a one take thing? Oh, no, that's right. We did, at the end of the song, he goes,
我开始尝试转圈。我想，不，你不能这样做。然后转回来，我太害怕了。你，但那是在现场观众面前。你必须拍多次吗，还是像一次过的那种？哦，不，没错。我们拍了，在歌曲结束时，他说，
what do you do if you like something that much? And everybody said, do it again. And so they did, and they filmed it twice. Wow, wow. So, but it was in the middle of a concert, right? Yeah. Yeah, it was in the middle of a concert. And that song was just, was it on the radio yet,
如果你那么喜欢某样东西你会怎么做？每个人都说，再来一次。所以他们做了，他们拍了两次。哇，哇。所以，但那是在演唱会中间，对吧？是啊。是啊，那是在演唱会中间。那首歌当时，在电台里了吗，
even when you guys did that? I think so. That was his first number one single. Right, so it was huge. And it became number one because of the video, basically. I mean, that video was just on all the time. Yeah, all the time. It was like Michael Jackson's thriller,
甚至在你们做那个的时候？我想是吧。那是他的第一首冠军单曲。对，所以它很火。它之所以成为冠军是因为那个MV，基本上。我的意思是，那个MV一直都在播。是啊，一直都在。就像迈克尔·杰克逊的《Thriller》，
and then Dancing in the Dark. They actually filmed a lot more than what was in it. And I remember watching, like we walked in, and we got t-shirts, and went to the bathroom, and put makeup on, and put our little muscle shirts on, and. Oh, wow. Wait, they shot all that?
然后是《Dancing in the Dark》。他们实际上拍的比放出来的多得多。我记得看着，就像我们走进去，我们拿了T恤，去了洗手间，化了妆，穿上我们的小肌肉背心，然后。哦，哇。等等，他们拍了所有这些？
That was part of it? They shot all this stuff. And then, so on the phone with my mom, as the video's premiering on MTV, it was a big deal. And I was like, mom, I got this video, and you're gonna see me? And it's like, I swear I'm coming on. And we waited, I'm only in the last 24 seconds.
那是其中的一部分？他们拍了所有这些东西。然后，所以在我妈妈的电话里，当MV在MTV首播时，那是一件大事。我就说，妈妈，我拍了这个MV，你会看到我吗？就像，我发誓我快出来了。我们等啊等，我只在最后24秒出现。
I was kind of embarrassed about talking to my mom about it, but no one else knew, so I guess that was fine. So you auditioned for that as an actress, and then was there a bump from that that led to more and bigger opportunities in acting? Was it beneficial to you? Yeah, you know, I've always done things with people that everybody else wants to know about.
我有点不好意思跟我妈谈这个，但没别人知道，所以我想那没关系。所以你作为一名演员试镜了那个，然后从那之后有没有得到提升，从而带来了更多更大的表演机会？这对你有益吗？是啊，你知道，我总是和每个人都想了解的人一起做事。
So if nothing else, people would want to see me because I was the girl in the Bruce Springsteen video, and everyone was like, how, what's Bruce really like? And then I did Family Ties. I was like, what's Michael J. Fox really like? And then I did Friends, and it was like, what's Jennifer Anderson really like? What, well, wait, what was,
所以即使别的什么都没有，人们也会想看我，因为我是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀MV里的那个女孩，每个人都会问，布鲁斯本人到底是什么样的？然后我拍了《成长的烦恼》。我就像，迈克尔·J·福克斯本人到底是什么样的？然后我拍了《老友记》，就像，詹妮弗·安妮斯顿本人到底是什么样的？什么，好吧，等等，什么是，
so talk to me a bit about your Family Ties experience, because obviously somebody who's close to our show has a connection to Family Ties as well. All right. Sean? What's up, JP? Did I ever see you there? I wonder, did I?
所以跟我聊聊你的《成长的烦恼》经历，因为显然我们节目的一位亲密伙伴也和《成长的烦恼》有联系。好吧。肖恩？怎么了，JP？我见过你吗？我想知道，我见过吗？
You must have. Well, I don't. Because I would go there after I would get wrapped from my show, because I would get off earlier because I was younger, and then I remember doing my homework in the stands, watching Justine finish up rehearsals. Jason, tell Tracy what, your connection?
你一定见过。嗯，我不记得了。因为我会在我的节目收工后去那儿，因为我年纪小所以收工早，然后我记得我在看台上做作业，看着贾斯汀完成排练。杰森，告诉特蕾西，你的联系？
My sister was on Family Ties. She played Mallory. Right. And then so Courtney, you came onto Family Ties. What season was that? The last two years. Last two years. And what was that experience like?
我姐姐在《成长的烦恼》里。她演马洛里。对。然后柯特妮，你加入了《成长的烦恼》。那是第几季？最后两年。最后两年。那次经历是什么样的？
Because Family Ties was huge. It was a huge, massive hit. I loved it. Followed the Cosby show, I think, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think so. That was nerve-wracking, because being a guest star, first of all, they've been doing it forever,
因为《成长的烦恼》很火。那是一个巨大的、大规模的热门剧。我喜欢它。紧接着《考斯比一家》之后，我想，对吧？是啊，是啊，是啊。我想是吧。那让人神经紧张，因为作为客串明星，首先，他们已经演了很久了，
and they're so comfortable, and it's just like second nature to them. But it was a big deal for me. And coming on, I just remember, you remember the character Skippy? Yeah, yeah. Well, we called ourselves the B players. And Scott Valentine, was that, am I saying that?
他们非常自在，这对他们来说就像第二天性。但对我来说这是一件大事。加入的时候，我只记得，你记得斯基皮那个角色吗？是啊，是啊。嗯，我们自称是B队球员。还有斯科特·瓦伦丁，是这样吗，我没说错吧？
I think so. And we would always say, oh, the B players are here. And for some reason, you kind of felt like you had to start over each time, because you might not be in for three episodes, and then it was like the first time again. But Gary David Goldberg was the nicest man in the world,
我想是吧。我们总是说，哦，B队球员来了。出于某种原因，你觉得每次都得重新开始，因为你可能连续三集都没戏份，然后就像第一次一样。但加里·大卫·戈德堡是世界上最好的人，
the creator of the show. This was the boss of the show, yeah. And then also Michael J. Fox, it's just so sweet. He was already married at that point, and he, to the other girlfriend, Tracy Pollan, who was on Before Me, and she was really sweet. Oh my God, that's right. Have you ever,
节目的创作者。这是节目的老板，是啊。还有迈克尔·J·福克斯，他太甜了。他当时已经结婚了，他，和另一个女朋友，特蕾西·波伦，她在我也之前就在那儿，她真的很甜。哦，天哪，没错。你有没有，
you know, like when you are a regular on a show, and you have guest stars come in, it's almost like having a guest at your house, right? It's something because it's your home, it's your workplace, and you have this relationship with everybody. Has there ever been an experience where you guest on a show like Family Tizer,
你知道，当你是一部剧的常驻演员，有客串明星进来时，就像家里有客人一样，对吧？因为那是你的家，你的工作场所，你和每个人都有这种关系。有没有过这样的经历，你在像《成长的烦恼》这样的节目里客串，
anytime in your life, you don't have to say what the show is, or who the people are, where you didn't have a welcoming feeling, and you were like, this doesn't feel good. And you know what, when I have a show, when I'm a regular, I'm gonna turn this around and make everybody feel welcome,
你生命中的任何时候，你不必说是什么节目，或者人是谁，你没有受到欢迎的感觉，你觉得，这感觉不好。你知道吗，当我有一部剧，当我是一个常驻演员时，我要扭转局面，让每个人都感到受欢迎，
which goes back to the caretaking thing when people go to your house. Oh, okay, well, I don't, I have to think about the guest starring thing. Because I don't think I've ever been comfortable, not that people haven't been nice, but I don't think they reach out as much as I did, and you're right.
这回到了人们去你家时的照顾问题。哦，好吧，我不知道，我得想想客串明星的事情。因为我不觉得我曾经感到自在，不是说人们不友好，但我不觉得他们像我那样主动，你是对的。
So on Friends, first of all, we have run-throughs on Wednesdays, or we did, I love that I'm still on the show, it's been 15, 20 years, I don't know. But when we have our run-throughs on Wednesday, so many people would get fired. Oh, really? Like friends of mine.
所以在《老友记》上，首先，我们周三有通读排练，或者我们曾经有，我喜欢我还在节目里，已经15、20年了，我不知道。但当我们在周三进行通读时，很多人会被解雇。哦，真的吗？就像我的朋友们。
Really? Yeah, and I would feel, I would always feel so bad, because they only had one shot at doing a rehearsal, and then Wednesday, the network would come through, and that would be it. Yeah. And so I would either send flowers, or I would call,
真的吗？是啊，我总是会觉得很糟糕，因为他们只有一次排练的机会，然后周三，电视网的人会过来，那就结束了。是啊。所以我要么送花，要么打电话，
I felt so bad for them. Oh, that's very nice. I know, it sounds really stupid, but. But can you imagine the pressure? Well, you, I was gonna say, can you imagine, of course you can, because you went on Family Ties, which was a huge hit as a guest,
我为他们感到难过。哦，那太好了。我知道，这听起来很蠢，但是。但你能想象那种压力吗？嗯，你，我正想说，你能想象吗，当然你可以，因为你去了《成长的烦恼》，那是一个巨大的热门剧，作为客串，
and so you know that pressure, but can you imagine going to Friends, and being a guest star, and you have like one scene, and you've got like five lines, and you've got to score at that run-through in front of the network, and the pressure of the,
所以你知道那种压力，但你能想象去《老友记》，作为一个客串明星，你只有一场戏，你有五句台词，你必须在电视网面前的通读中表现出色，而且压力，
not just the number one show on TV, the number one show on the planet, and guess what, dude, if you don't hit it, like that must have been, I went out and I did Sean's show, Will and Grace, years ago. They tried to fire him so hard. And they tried so hard,
不仅仅是电视上排名第一的节目，是地球上排名第一的节目，猜猜怎么着，伙计，如果你没演好，那一定，我以前去演过肖恩的节目，《威尔和格蕾丝》。他们拼命想解雇他。他们尝试得太努力了，
and Jimmy Burroughs was the only one who said, nah, give him another chance, honey. But I knew that pressure. Will and Grace at that time was a top five, top 10 show. It was like a massive hit, and I was like, well, better be good. It's so true. It's scary as a performer.
只有吉米·伯罗斯说，不，亲爱的，再给他一次机会。但我知道那种压力。《威尔和格蕾丝》在当时是前五、前十的节目。那是一个巨大的热门剧，我就想，嗯，最好表现好点。这太真实了。作为表演者，这很可怕。
You scored big time. And all these movie actors would come on, and they would be so nervous, but of course they would never be fired, but. No. And we will be right back. Court, you know what I love? I saw you cooking, and I was like, and everything.
你得分很高。所有这些电影演员都会来，他们会非常紧张，但当然他们永远不会被解雇，但是。不。我们马上回来。柯特，你知道我喜欢什么吗？我看到你在做饭，我就想，还有所有的一切。
I love that. I love it. I'm like obsessed with your, whenever you have an Instagram post about you cooking, because you do the thing that where you, it's like, look, it's really easy. You just chop this up, you do this, you do this. And I was like, first of all,
我喜欢那个。我喜欢它。我简直着迷于你的，每当你发布关于你做饭的Instagram帖子时，因为你做那种事情，就像，看，这真的很简单。你只要把它切碎，你这样做，你这样做。我就想，首先，
where did the love come from? Why is it so exciting for me? It's so entertaining. I can't take my eyes off it. And what do you get out of it? So wait, what is this? You're talking to a granddad that doesn't have, or not on the Instagram.
这种爱从哪儿来的？为什么对我来说这么令人兴奋？这太有趣了。我无法把目光从上面移开。你从中得到了什么？等等，这是什么？你在和一个没有，或者不在Instagram上的爷爷说话。
Oh, she could. It's like live recipes. No, she takes you through the process of cooking. Courtney, you tell us. Okay, so when lockdown happened, I, my hobbies just went through the roof. I started cooking every single night. I started playing the piano more,
哦，她可以。就像现场食谱。不，她带你走过烹饪的过程。柯特妮，你告诉我们。好吧，所以当封锁发生时，我的爱好简直爆棚了。我开始每天晚上做饭。我开始更多地弹钢琴，
or, you know, got pretty decent at it. Yeah, very good. Played tennis. I really did a lot of stuff. And then I, for some reason, Instagram, which takes up so much time. I don't know why I, I don't know why do I have to do these little videos?
或者，你知道，弹得还不错。是啊，非常好。打网球。我真的做了很多事情。然后我，出于某种原因，Instagram，占用了太多时间。我不知道为什么我，我不知道为什么我必须做这些小视频？
Why can't I just be the person that posts the sunset? No, I have to edit them and put music to them. It's just so stupid. But anyway, yeah, cooking has been great. I just, well, I really take someone else's recipe and either simplify it or act like it's really easy. Courtney, Courtney, what I love, you touch on, you mentioned something which is great.
为什么我不能只是那个发布日落的人？不，我必须编辑它们并配上音乐。这太蠢了。但无论如何，是啊，烹饪一直很棒。我只是，嗯，我真的拿别人的食谱，要么简化它，要么表现得好像它真的很简单。柯特妮，柯特妮，我喜欢的是，你触及了，你提到了某件事，这很棒。
First of all, you're cooking. You should know Courtney gave me this great home, sort of steak sauce recipe, which was, and Courtney, I don't want to take it away from you. You tell us what it is. Because I still use it. I told you that I still use it to this day. She told me.
首先，你在做饭。你应该知道柯特妮给了我这个很棒的家庭，某种牛排酱食谱，那是，柯特妮，我不想把它从你那儿拿走。你告诉我们那是什么。因为我还在用它。我告诉过你我至今还在用它。她告诉我的。
It's called cream of mushroom soup. It's a bachelor's gravy. No, no, listen. The bachelor's gravy. What is cream of mushroom? Is the bachelor's? Cream of mushroom soup, yeah, from a Campbell's can. It's the bachelor's gravy.
它叫奶油蘑菇汤。这是单身汉的肉汁。不，不，听着。单身汉的肉汁。什么是奶油蘑菇？是单身汉的？奶油蘑菇汤，是啊，来自金宝罐头。这是单身汉的肉汁。
Oh yeah, I love a can. And I like my cranberry sauce at Thanksgiving. I want to see the ridges, because I think that's cute. But I get that. My dad used to make a sauce and it would be Heinz 57 mostly. That's the main ingredient.
哦，是啊，我喜欢罐头。我喜欢感恩节的蔓越莓酱。我想看到纹路，因为我觉得那很可爱。但我明白。我爸爸过去常做一种酱，主要是亨氏57。那是主要成分。
A1 Worcestershire sauce, however you say that. And just a little bit of ketchup. Yeah. It's a really good sauce. It's incredible. And to this day, years ago, Courtney's like, this is what you need to use, blah, blah, blah. I did it incredible to this day.
A1伍斯特沙司，无论你怎么说那个。还有一点番茄酱。是啊。这是一种非常好的酱。太不可思议了。直到今天，几年前，柯特妮说，这就是你需要用的，等等等等。我做了，至今都很不可思议。
I still use it. So I love that. So thank you. Great tip. And if you're out there, let us know. We'll read it in the comments. Well, do you have any desire to cook? You don't cook, do you?
我还在用它。所以我喜欢那个。所以谢谢你。很棒的建议。如果你在外面，让我们知道。我们会在评论里读到它。嗯，你有做饭的欲望吗？你不做饭，对吧？
I don't. I do have that desire, but it feels like, I wish I knew. It's one of those things. I wish I knew how to cook. I wish I knew how to play piano. And this is what I was going to get to. It kind of feeds right into,
我不做。我确实有那种欲望，但感觉就像，我希望我知道。这是其中之一。我希望我知道怎么做饭。我希望我知道怎么弹钢琴。这就是我要说的。它直接导向，
Courtney, you're talking about like you, when you focus on stuff, you get into it. So like tennis you mentioned, you're a really good tennis player. You're like, and you're very modest about everything that you do. You've got really good at piano. You're good at cooking.
柯特妮，你在谈论就像你，当你专注于某事时，你会投入进去。所以就像你提到的网球，你是一个非常好的网球运动员。你就像，而且你对你所做的一切都非常谦虚。你钢琴弹得很好。你擅长烹饪。
You're kind of good at everything because you focus on it and you spend the time on it. Where does that come from? Like that kind of, you have that great discipline. I said it before, you're very disciplined. I think that because we've had so much time, but I really have pretty bad ADD. So if I take a piano lesson, it's not one hour.
你几乎擅长一切，因为你专注于它，你花时间在上面。那从哪儿来的？就像那种，你有那种伟大的纪律。我之前说过，你非常有纪律。我想是因为我们有太多的时间，但我确实有相当严重的ADD。所以如果我上一节钢琴课，那不是一小时。
It's four hours because we get up. I go off and do something. It's never really focused, but I do stick with stuff. And I do love the piano so much. I love it, love it, love it. It's brought a lot of joy. And I've actually, did you see that post where I played with Elton John?
是四小时，因为我们起来了。我走开去做别的事。它从来没有真正专注过，但我确实坚持做事情。而且我确实非常喜欢钢琴。我喜欢它，喜欢它，喜欢它。它带来了很多快乐。而且我实际上，你看到那个我和埃尔顿·约翰一起演奏的帖子了吗？
Yes. Yes, that was crazy. I mean, do you understand the thrill that was? It was insane. It was holding my arm. And I was like, wait, I don't, I don't, I won't get to hold my arm, but how am I going to play?
是的。是的，那太疯狂了。我的意思是，你明白那有多激动人心吗？太疯狂了。他握着我的手臂。我就想，等等，我没有，我没有，我没能握住我的手臂，但我怎么弹？
I'm so nervous. And Brandy Carlyle was singing behind me and Ed was next to me. But that was Ed's idea to do that. It was the song, Hold Me Closer, Kind Dancer. Ed Sheeran. Oh, sorry. No, it's for my sister.
我太紧张了。布兰迪·卡莱尔在我身后唱歌，埃德在我旁边。但那是埃德的主意。那是那首歌，《Hold Me Closer, Tiny Dancer》。埃德·希兰。哦，抱歉。不，那是为了我姐姐。
So we did the song to Lisa Kujo, Hold Me Closer, Tony Danza. And Lisa does a post back and says, I really like the song, but it's not, it's Hold Me Close, Young Tony Danza. We got it wrong. She's so funny. That's hilarious.
所以我们唱了那首歌给丽莎·库卓，《Hold Me Closer, Tony Danza》。丽莎回帖说，我真的很喜欢这首歌，但它不是，它是《Hold Me Close, Young Tony Danza》。我们弄错了。她太搞笑了。那太搞笑了。
But you've had these incredible Sunday night soirees. So you talk about the family, but also, like you said, you have like skits. It's a little different from your grandmother's house where everybody's doing a skit. I was there once in Taylor Swift, played in your living room, or, you know, like just like crazy Ed Sheeran, et cetera, et cetera.
但你举办了这些不可思议的周日晚宴。所以你谈论家庭，但也像你说的，你有短剧。这和你祖母家每个人都在演短剧有点不同。我曾经去过一次，泰勒·斯威夫特在你的客厅里演奏，或者，你知道，就像疯狂的埃德·希兰，等等等等。
It goes on. Music is so important to you. Obviously, Johnny, your boyfriend is an incredible musician, songwriter, performer, everything. That's a really, do you feel like you missed your calling a little bit? If I was really good, I would have been for sure in music and been in a band.
还在继续。音乐对你来说太重要了。显然，约翰尼，你的男朋友是一位不可思议的音乐家、词曲作者、表演者，一切。那真的，你觉得你错过了一点你的使命吗？如果我真的很好，我肯定会从事音乐并加入一个乐队。
I just wish I'd started earlier, not started when I'm 50. Well, that's what I mean. Like you, did it like, did it hit you like, oh gosh, I should have done, this was what I should have been doing. Cause it brings you so much to life. I love it.
我只是希望我开始得更早，而不是在50岁时才开始。嗯，这就是我的意思。就像你，它是否击中了你，就像，哦天哪，我应该做，这就是我应该做的事情。因为它让你如此生动。我喜欢它。
Yeah, exactly. I wish I was a musician, a real one. That's how I actually, yeah, Sunday nights have been great. That's how I met Johnny is that he was brought over by Ed. You summoned him. Yeah. Yeah, you did.
是啊，完全正确。我希望我是一名音乐家，一个真正的音乐家。这就是我实际上，是啊，周日晚上一直很棒。这就是我遇到约翰尼的方式，是他被埃德带过来的。你召唤了他。是啊。是啊，你做到了。
It just happened, yeah. The universe, the universe served him up. We believe in that. You know, I believe in that. Well, you could, I mean, you've got plenty of time. You could sort of, you could weave some music into the next chapter in your career. I mean, what would that do, right?
它就这样发生了，是啊。宇宙，宇宙把他送来了。我们相信那个。你知道，我相信那个。嗯，你可以，我的意思是，你有足够的时间。你可以某种程度上，你可以把一些音乐编织进你职业生涯的下一个篇章。我的意思是，那会怎么样，对吧？
What would be the natural transition to that? That would be, if you were in a punk band, like a really, if you played heavy metal, you guys could be called Courtney and the Hardcocks. And I'm just saying, no, because it would be a heavy, like really. Yeah, that would be good. I'd listen to that.
那自然的过渡会是什么？那会是，如果你在一个朋克乐队里，就像一个真的，如果你演奏重金属，你们可以叫“柯特妮和硬公鸡”。我只是说，不，因为那会是一个沉重的，就像真的。是啊，那会很棒。我会听那个。
But Court, would you ever write stuff or would you ever like challenge yourself? I wrote one song about, it's so many years ago. With Johnny? No, I've never written a song with Johnny. No. Johnny has written like so many huge hits. It's insane.
但柯特，你会写东西吗，或者你会挑战自己吗？我写过一首歌，那是很多年前的事了。和约翰尼一起？不，我从来没和约翰尼写过歌。不。约翰尼写过很多巨大的热门歌曲。太疯狂了。
Tell my sister who Johnny is. Okay, so Johnny McDade is in Snow Patrol, but really as another, not his side job, but an incredible part of his career is that he writes with Ed. He wrote Bad Habits, I mean, yes, Bad Habits, but he also wrote Shape of You. He's written with Ed, probably 90% of his last album
告诉我姐姐约翰尼是谁。好吧，所以约翰尼·麦克戴德在雪地巡游者乐队，但实际上作为另一个，不是他的副业，而是他职业生涯中不可思议的一部分是，他和埃德一起写歌。他写了《Bad Habits》，我的意思是，是的，《Bad Habits》，但他还写了《Shape of You》。他和埃德一起写了，可能他上一张专辑的90%
and even other ones in the past. Amazing. He also wrote Like What About Us with Pink and he wrote Underdog with Alicia Keys. But he writes with people all the time. Louis Capaldi, he's just incredible. He's a poet. Have you ever talked to him about maybe writing
甚至过去的其他专辑。太棒了。他还写了像Pink的《What About Us》，他还写了艾丽西亚·凯斯的《Underdog》。但他一直和人们一起写歌。路易斯·卡帕尔迪，他简直不可思议。他是一位诗人。你有没有和他谈过也许写
a song with him? Well, what am I gonna do once I have it? I can't sing. Yes, you can. No, no, no, but you can just be a songwriter, like participate in his songwriting endeavors. Like, does he ever like run some lyrics by you and you go, oh, but what if you say X, Y, and Z?
一首歌和他一起？嗯，我一旦有了它我该做什么？我不会唱歌。是的，你可以。不，不，不，但你可以只是成为一名词曲作者，就像参与他的词曲创作努力。就像，他有没有曾经把一些歌词给你看，然后你说，哦，但如果你说X、Y和Z会怎样？
And he goes, oh, Courtney, that's great. Oh, sorry. Hey, guys, accent alert. Here we go. Guys, Johnny's here. Oh, Tarp of the Merni-Tier. You didn't want to just throw in Lucky Charms while you're at it.
然后他说，哦，柯特妮，那太棒了。哦，抱歉。嘿，伙计们，口音警报。我们来了。伙计们，约翰尼在这儿。哦，Tarp of the Merni-Tier。你不想在顺便的时候也扔进幸运符麦片吗。
How offensive. I did. I wrote one song, I mean, one line of a song and a birdie song, it's called Wild Horses. And I was thinking that song was very much like I Will Survive by Gloria Gaynor. And so one of the lines was, I will not beg you to stay. And that was my contribution to that song.
多冒犯啊。我做了。我写了一首歌，我的意思是，一首歌的一行，一首小鸟歌，它叫《Wild Horses》。我当时想那首歌非常像格洛丽亚·盖纳的《I Will Survive》。所以其中一行是，我不会乞求你留下。那就是我对那首歌的贡献。
Oh, wow. But I will say Johnny doesn't sound as much like an Irish leprechaun who's that bad to say I'm canceled now. Okay, as he's from Northern Ireland, it's the hardest accent to do. Can you, do you do it, Johnny? Of course, got it.
哦，哇。但我得说约翰尼听起来不像一个爱尔兰小妖精，说我被取消了太糟糕了。好吧，因为他来自北爱尔兰，这是最难模仿的口音。你能，你模仿一下吗，约翰尼？当然，明白了。
Courtney? I mean, it's now is, no, it's so hard, yeah. Hey, Will, have you ever tried to do Johnny? Let's hear it, let's hear it. No. That's pretty good. Courtney, are you there? No.
柯特妮？我的意思是，现在是，不，这太难了，是啊。嘿，威尔，你有没有试过模仿约翰尼？让我们听听，让我们听听。不。那相当不错。柯特妮，你在那儿吗？不。
That's really good. It's not bad, it's not bad. So I mean, yeah, he's just such a mega talent and so that must, that being, having that sort of in your life, must be so satisfying like that. Yeah, it is. Because you guys are always,
那真的很好。不坏，不坏。所以我的意思是，是啊，他简直是一个超级天才，所以那一定，拥有那种在你的生活中，一定非常令人满足，就像那样。是啊，确实。因为你们总是，
he's always creating and you're creating and you get to, you're in that thing. I mean, that's exhilarating. It would be like, it would be like, I'd have to marry Shani, I guess. That would be the equivalent. Brendan Shanahan, friend of the show. Well, now, Court, can we talk about the challenges
他总是创造，你也在创造，你能够，你在那件事里。我的意思是，那令人振奋。那会就像，那会就像，我得娶莎妮，我想。那会是等价的。布兰登·沙纳汉，节目的朋友。好吧，现在，柯特，我们可以谈谈挑战吗
of being in love with somebody who's a half a planet away? That is challenging. Yeah, he lives in London and I live here. He spent a lot of time on FaceTime and for some reason I have the worst internet in the world. So half the time it's just not working. And because he's so technological and I'm not,
爱上一个远在半个地球之外的人？那很有挑战性。是啊，他住在伦敦，我住在这儿。他花了很多时间在FaceTime上，出于某种原因，我有世界上最烂的网络。所以有一半时间它根本无法工作。而且因为他很懂技术，而我不懂，
I don't know how to fix anything. I just go, I don't know. And that seems to be our biggest conflict is our FaceTime. What you guys do get to be in person. Reboot, reboot the router. Turn it off, turn it on. Turn off the router.
我不知道怎么修理任何东西。我只是说，我不知道。那似乎是我们最大的冲突，我们的FaceTime。你们确实能亲自见面。重启，重启路由器。关掉它，打开它。关掉路由器。
Started again. But how often do you see him? How often do you not see him? Like, what's the ratio? Jesus, guys, we're getting really, then on a very special smart list. Yeah, no, we're getting personal. Oh, no, I just, well,
重新开始。但你多久见他一次？你多久不见他一次？就像，比例是多少？天哪，伙计们，我们变得非常，然后在非常特别的《Smart List》上。是啊，不，我们变得私人了。哦，不，我只是，好吧，
okay, we didn't see each other very much during the first part of the lockdown. Even when I could have, I was with my brother and he was riding with Ed up in Suffolk and that was kind of tough. But now I go there a lot. I feel like I go there once a month or he doesn't come here as much.
好的，我们在封锁的第一部分没怎么见面。即使我可以的时候，我和我哥哥在一起，他在萨福克和埃德一起骑车，那有点艰难。但现在我经常去那儿。我觉得我一个月去一次，或者他不怎么来这儿。
Just because I think, well, first of all, he was opened up in November to America, to people outside of the UK. Right, right, right. So yeah, I go there a lot. But for a while, because of COVID, he was like, don't even go there. Yeah, I mean, it was just hard.
只是因为我想，好吧，首先，他在十一月向美国开放了，向英国以外的人。对，对，对。所以是啊，我经常去那儿。但有一段时间，因为新冠，他就像，甚至别去那儿。是啊，我的意思是，那太难了。
He couldn't come here and I was busy with my brother. What about, are you, have you ever thought about moving to England or has he ever thought about moving here? Well, he used to live here. We lived together a long time ago and then he moved to London because we broke up for a little while and then,
他不能来这儿，我忙着和我哥哥在一起。关于，你，你有没有想过搬到英国，或者他有没有想过搬到这儿？嗯，他过去住在这儿。我们很久以前住在一起，然后他搬到了伦敦，因为我们分手了一小会儿，然后，
but once Coco goes to school, that will be a whole other thing. We could spend much more time together. You've been keeping her out of school all this whole time? You're gonna get arrested for that. Coco's going to school, right? Like college. Yeah, she got into her one choice.
但一旦可可去上学，那将是另一回事。我们可以花更多时间在一起。你一直让她不去上学吗？你会因为那个被捕的。可可要去上学，对吧？就像大学。是啊，她进了她的第一选择。
That's great. Nice. Yeah. That's great. I know, it's really exciting. Now, how are you gonna, just to keep you sad, how are you gonna deal with it when Courtney goes away to school?
那太棒了。不错。是啊。那太棒了。我知道，这真的很令人兴奋。现在，你打算怎么，只是为了让你难过，当柯特妮去上学时你打算怎么处理？
Have you have a strategy? I ask only because, what did I say? Courtney. Oh yeah, when Coco goes, because I'm asking only because I've already started thinking about my strategy with Franny and Maple. It's not going to be easy for me to be an empty nester. No.
你有策略吗？我问只是因为，我说了什么？柯特妮。哦，是的，当可可走的时候，因为我问只是因为我已经开始考虑我和弗兰妮还有梅普尔的策略了。对我来说成为空巢老人并不容易。不。
Are you going to follow her, do you think? Or are you just going to wallpaper your house with pictures of her? Well, you know, my sister, it was so hard for her when her kid, her last kid went off. And then I think of Johnny's sister, she started getting really upset the year before. I think Coco's prepping me, she's never home.
你打算跟着她吗，你觉得？还是你只是打算用她的照片贴满你的房子？嗯，你知道，我姐姐，当她的孩子，她的最后一个孩子离开时，这对她来说太难了。然后我想起约翰尼的姐姐，她在前一年就开始变得非常难过。我想可可正在准备我，她从不在家。
She's always in her room. So I don't even know if I'm gonna, like I'll miss a couple of things she does, they'll come into my room and we'll snuggle every now and then for a minute, then she'll say, can I go to someone's house when she's prepping? She's always prepping me for something. And I don't know, I'd love to maybe get a place
她总是在她的房间里。所以我甚至不知道我是否会，就像我会错过她做的一些事情，她们会进我的房间，我们偶尔会依偎一会儿，然后她会说，我能去某人家吗，当她在准备时？她总是为某事准备我。我不知道，我很乐意也许买个地方
or just be around her when she goes to college. And maybe buy a bunch of cats just to kind of compensate. Do you find yourself, you're always busy with work. I was gonna get back. So do you think that work will, when Coco does go, that you'll just kind of maybe occupy yourself a lot? And you're always, again, you're always very busy. You're doing a lot of stuff.
或者只是在她去上大学时在她身边。也许买一堆猫来补偿一下。你发现你自己，你总是忙于工作。我正要回来。所以你认为工作会，当可可走的时候，你会只是某种程度上也许占据你很多时间？而且你总是，再说一次，你总是很忙。你做了很多事情。
You've got a new show coming out on Starz soon, right? What's the show? It's called Shining Veil. It's on Starz airs March the sixth. I think that the last year has been the busiest year of my life. I'm starting a product line with Jason. I know, you know, cause you smell a lot of the stuff,
你有一部新剧很快要在Starz上播出，对吧？是什么剧？它叫《Shining Veil》。它在Starz上，三月六日播出。我想过去的一年是我一生中最忙的一年。我正在和杰森一起创办一个产品线。我知道，你知道，因为你闻了很多东西，
the candles and you've given me good opinions. Let's take those by the number. So you're doing the new show on Starz. Talk a little bit about what it is. Okay, so the show is, it's got Greg Keneer and Mira Sovino and Gus Bernie and I always panic. You can come back. Jake Dylan.
蜡烛，你给了我很好的意见。让我们按数字来谈谈那些。所以你在Starz上做新剧。谈谈它是什么。好吧，所以这部剧是，它有格雷格·金尼尔和米拉·索维诺和格斯·伯尼，我总是恐慌。你可以回来。杰克·迪伦。
And it's great. It's about a woman who was going through menopause and well, I should, why didn't I just say midlife crisis? Why don't I have to go to menopause, but... Yeah, you see whatever you want. It's both. And she has an affair with the handyman. She wants to start her life over
这太棒了。故事讲的是一个正在经历更年期的女人，好吧，我应该，我为什么不直接说中年危机呢？为什么非得是更年期，但是……是的，你想怎么看都行。两者都有。她和杂工有了外遇。她想重新开始她的生活
and they moved to Connecticut into a haunted house. And only the only person that can see the ghost is me and everybody else thinks I'm psycho. So it's a comedy, but it's also, it's a thriller. And that's kind of a genre of bending thing because it's not a comedy like Scream where Scream is, it's a slasher. By the way, congratulations on Scream.
他们搬到了康涅狄格州的一栋鬼屋里。唯一能看到鬼的人是我，而其他人都觉得我精神有问题。所以这是一部喜剧，但它也是一部惊悚片。这算是一种类型融合，因为它不像《惊声尖叫》那种喜剧，因为《惊声尖叫》是砍杀片。顺便说一句，恭喜《惊声尖叫》大获成功。
Scream is a huge hit right now. Huge hit. So you've had, I was gonna say this. So you've actually had a lot of success in that kind of like, I know that Scream is kind of over the top and it's a comedy, but it's also a scary... Genre. Yeah, genre.
《惊声尖叫》现在非常火。非常火。所以你已经，我正想说这个。你实际上在那类电影中取得了很大的成功，我知道《惊声尖叫》有点夸张，它是部喜剧，但它也是一部恐怖……类型片。是的，类型片。
But that, is that something that you've always been attracted to or you've thought about? I'm not really like horror films, but I mean, I have, that was my fifth one to do. But I do like to be, I mean, I love to be, well, I shouldn't say this because then people will scare me and I don't really like to be scared.
但那是你一直以来感兴趣或考虑过的吗？我其实不太喜欢恐怖片，但是，我是说，那是我拍的第五部了。但我确实喜欢，我是说，我喜欢，好吧，我不该这么说，因为那样人们会吓唬我，而我其实并不喜欢被吓到。
So what I think I do, I like those kind of movies. What if I was doing the zoom from the next room right next to you? You mean like, what if the podcast was coming from inside the house? Well, I will say after I saw this last Scream, I'm certain Ghostface is somewhere, I would like to go up,
所以我认为我做的是，我喜欢那种电影。如果我就在你隔壁的房间里用变焦镜头拍你呢？你是说，如果播客是从房子里面传出来的呢？好吧，我得说，看完这部最新的《惊声尖叫》后，我确信鬼脸就在某处，我想上去，
if the dogs wake up in the middle of the night, I'm so scared because it's dark and I don't really know. I take a flashlight, but I'm certain someone's gonna jump out. Yeah. We will be right back. Do you have any funny fears? Like I got one about bees.
如果狗在半夜醒来，我会非常害怕，因为天很黑，我真的不知道。我拿着手电筒，但我确信会有人跳出来。好的。我们马上回来。你有什么好笑的恐惧症吗？比如我就怕蜜蜂。
I just can't, bees, just wreck my day. Bees? Bees? Bees. Bees. Bees. Bees. Do you have like, are you, do you look under the bed? Do you avoid walking under ladders? Do you, do you have a fear of earthquakes?
我就是不行，蜜蜂，简直毁了我的一天。蜜蜂？蜜蜂？蜜蜂。蜜蜂。蜜蜂。蜜蜂。你有没有，你会看床底下吗？你会避免从梯子下走过吗？你，你害怕地震吗？
Like what's your funny fear? I think my fear would be of birds. Birds? I don't like things flapping around me. Birds, birds. Yeah, or like a bird, if there's a crow outside, cause those are big, those crows, I'm certain they're gonna come peck me.
比如你有什么好笑的恐惧症？我想我的恐惧症应该是鸟。鸟？我不喜欢有东西在我周围扑腾。鸟，鸟。是的，或者像鸟，如果外面有一只乌鸦，因为那些家伙很大，那些乌鸦，我确信它们会来啄我。
Birds are dinosaurs, closer than lizards are. Oh, thanks doctor. So, uh, Sean, what's your funny fear? My funny fear. Oh boy, here we go. There's a two hour episode.
鸟类是恐龙，比蜥蜴更接近恐龙。哦，谢谢医生。那么，肖恩，你有什么好笑的恐惧症？我好笑的恐惧症。天哪，开始了。这有一集两小时的节目。
What is it? I guess. Women, there we go. Will. Jesus. I fear nothing. And back to Courtney. No, wait, what is my fear?
是什么？我猜。女人，好了。威尔。天哪。我什么都不怕。回到考特尼身上。不，等等，我的恐惧症是什么？
My fear is, I have a fear of bees a little bit. I have a little, I understand the bird thing. Mine's gotten better. What's that? I'm sorry, mine's gotten better, but it's still there. Go ahead, birds you can relate to as well. Yeah, what is my fear? Spiders?
我的恐惧症是，我有一点怕蜜蜂。我有一点，我理解鸟类那个。我的好多了。那是什么？抱歉，我的好多了，但它还在。继续，鸟类你也能感同身受。是的，我的恐惧症是什么？蜘蛛？
No, I don't fear spiders. Cockroaches, cockroaches, rats. I don't know. How about food that is moldy that you can't see until you're chewing it? Oh. I have a fear. I gotta always check the strawberries,
不，我不怕蜘蛛。蟑螂，蟑螂，老鼠。我不知道。发霉的食物怎么样，你嚼的时候才发现？哦。我有一个恐惧。我总是得检查草莓，
check the blueberries. That's weird that it's food-related. Fuck me, man. I have a fear of losing gas in my car, of like driving and not looking down at this and being- You drive a Tesla. No, I don't. Scotty, no.
检查蓝莓。这很奇怪，竟然和食物有关。去你的，伙计。我害怕车里没油，比如开车时没看仪表盘，然后——你开的是特斯拉。不，我不是。斯科蒂，别这样。
You've got no gas in your car. How about a spider in the toilet? A spider in the toilet. It's gonna crawl up your ass. Yeah, I had this fear for years and years and years and years based on nothing and then last year. Again, the universe delivered it. There was a spider in my toilet and I was like,
你车里没油了。马桶里有蜘蛛怎么样？马桶里有蜘蛛。它会爬进你的屁股。是的，我多年来一直有这种恐惧，毫无根据，然后去年。宇宙又一次实现了它。马桶里真的有一只蜘蛛，我当时就觉得，
I thought I was just being a freak. It really can happen. No, cause you thought about it long enough. If you think about something, the universe will deliver it. Hang on guys, everyone listening? Go ahead. What about those centipedes,
我以为我只是在发疯。它真的会发生。不，因为你想得够久了。如果你一直想某件事，宇宙就会把它送到你面前。等等，伙计们，大家都在听吗？继续。那些蜈蚣怎么样，
this one with all the little legs? You know, talking about the longs? I once found a centipede in the house I was renting in New Mexico where it's lousy with centipedes and it was in the middle of the night. I was watching a Dodger game at like 2.30 in the morning. I saw this little thing skitter across the floor and there was, my mattress was on the floor in this house.
就是那种有很多小腿的？你知道，说的是长的那种？我曾经在新墨西哥州租的房子里发现过一只蜈蚣，那里蜈蚣泛滥，那是半夜。我在凌晨2点半左右看道奇队的比赛。我看到这小东西在地上爬，而且，我的床垫就在那房子的地板上。
So I knew I had to find the centipede if I had any hope of getting any rest. Sounds like you were holed up. Were you like in a hostage situation with a mattress on the floor in New Mexico? It wasn't a high end dreadful. The bathtub full of math. Were you cooking?
所以我知道如果我想休息，就必须找到那只蜈蚣。听起来你像是被困住了。你是在新墨西哥州地板上铺着床垫的人质吗？那不是什么高端恐怖片。浴缸里装满了数学题。你在做饭吗？
It took me so long to find the centipede. When I finally did, I stamped down on it so hard with my heel that I bruised my heel. I couldn't walk straight for a week. Wait, wait, did you wear shoes to do this? I had slippers on, you know me. And Christian had slippers on.
我找那只蜈蚣找了很久。当我终于找到它时，我用脚后跟狠狠地踩了下去，结果把脚后跟踩伤了。我一个星期都走不了路。等等，等等，你穿鞋了吗？我穿着拖鞋，你了解我的。而且克里斯蒂安也穿着拖鞋。
Yeah, it was so nice. I had a friend of mine had a silver fish in his ear. Ooh, that is really nice. He had to go. He was like, why don't I have like a little bit of a headache? He went to and they pulled it out of his ear and it went in there when he was sleeping from his bed. Have you ever seen that thing?
是的，太好了。我有个朋友耳朵里进了银鱼。噢，那真是太好了。他不得不去。他当时想，为什么我有点头疼？他去了医院，他们把它从他耳朵里取了出来，那是他睡觉时从床上爬进去的。你见过那个东西吗？
Don't look a bot fly on YouTube. Have you ever seen a bot fly? No. Yeah, they're in the jungles of like Central and South America and they go and they burrow into your skull and then they reproduce. And so these people, like you see these videos of people who go back to England, they go to their doctor like,
别在YouTube上搜马蝇。你见过马蝇吗？没有。是的，它们生活在像中美洲和南美洲的丛林里，它们会钻进你的头骨里，然后繁殖。所以这些人，就像你看到的这些视频，人们回到英国，他们去看医生说，
Maya, go something that's sought of me at, haven't I? And then they go and they're like, and then this thing just, they pull out. Hey, Will, what website are you, what website have you been going to lately? We wrote a scene once for, we did that show, Running Wild Mitch and I, Hurwitz and Jimmy Valley.
玛雅，我身上好像有什么东西，不是吗？然后他们去检查，然后这东西就，他们把它取了出来。嘿，威尔，你最近在看什么网站？我们曾经写过一个场景，我们做了那个节目，《荒野求生》米奇和我，赫维茨和吉米·瓦利。
Holds for a pause. Yeah, we wrote this scene where we wanted to have David Cross is being held in like a quarantine because he's got a bot fly in his living in his head. That's funny. Courtney, what do you, but what's your number one fear? Would you say? Not just funny fear, real fear.
停顿一下。是的，我们写了这个场景，我们想让大卫·克罗斯被隔离，因为他的脑袋里住着一只马蝇。那很有趣。考特尼，你，但你最大的恐惧是什么？你会说？不仅仅是好笑的恐惧，真正的恐惧。
Yeah, is it anything about working? Like, do you fear not working? Do you love to work? Or do you have the perfect work-life balance now? Do you wish one was, well, don't, you're on her leading the way. I was asking. Maybe it's something to do in her personal life.
是的，和工作有关吗？比如，你害怕不工作吗？你热爱工作吗？还是你现在有了完美的工作与生活平衡？你希望其中一个，好吧，别，你正在引领潮流。我只是问问。也许和她的个人生活有关。
Maybe she's, it's not all about Hollywood haze. Hollywood haze, how do we ever thought of that? It's a new podcast. Well, I know people. What would be my biggest fear? Maybe that anything to do with Coco, like her not- Health of the kids. Something, yeah.
也许她，这不仅仅是好莱坞的迷雾。好莱坞迷雾，我们怎么会想到这个？这是一个新播客。好吧，我认识人。我最大的恐惧会是什么？也许是任何与可可有关的事，比如她没有——孩子的健康。某种，是的。
Or actually, Coco's heart. Yeah. I mean, I think she's, you think I'm a caretaker? Oh my God, Coco is the biggest caretaker. And then I always worry, I worry about her. That she's going to care for the wrong person? Or not about guys or relationships, but more about her, even just her friends.
或者实际上，可可的心脏。是的。我是说，我觉得她是，你觉得我是个照顾者？天哪，可可是最大的照顾者。然后我总是担心，我担心她。她会去照顾错误的人？或者不是关于男人或关系，而是更多关于她，甚至只是她的朋友。
Right. Hang on, Will's got a joke, go for it. As I say, Jason's biggest fear is living it out to the right on number four and being OB. What does that mean? Right? It's golf-related. It's out of bounds on the right side of the four-fairway.
对。等等，威尔有个笑话，说吧。正如我所说，杰森最大的恐惧是打到四号洞右侧的界外区，也就是OB。那是什么意思？对吧？这是高尔夫术语。是四号球道右侧的界外。
So, all right, so court. Now let's get out of fear and sadness and empty nesting. Now let's get into her product line, which I wanted to do, because that was the other thing. So you're so busy, which kind of goes to Sean, what you were saying, like, do you, is this because you have a fear of, where does that drive of like,
好吧，所以考特。现在让我们摆脱恐惧、悲伤和空巢综合症。现在让我们进入她的产品线，我想做这个，因为那是另一件事。所以你太忙了，这有点像肖恩说的，比如，你，这是因为你害怕，那种动力来自哪里，比如，
what was doing stuff? The fear of not smelling nice. No, but like, you've got like a million shows, and the reason I asked you, too, is because you produced this show, you produced Cougar Town, you've produced a lot of stuff that you've done, like you've always got so many things,
做这些事？害怕闻起来不香。不，但是，你有一百万个节目，我问你也是因为你制作了这个节目，你制作了《熟女镇》，你制作了很多你做过的事情，比如你总是有那么多事情，
and now you've added on this personal, how do you describe it, personal Caroline? Well, no, it's not, it's more of a home line, it's called home court. Nice. Like home court advantage, home court. Oh my God. That's really great.
现在你又增加了这个个人，你怎么描述它，个人卡罗琳？好吧，不，它更像是一个家居系列，叫Home Court。不错。就像主场优势，Home Court。天哪。那真的很棒。
But, so I love scents, and it's like, I love to mix oils and perfume. I love that. So I wanted to start a candle company, and then I thought, we spend so much time at home, and at first, of course, all of the smell of Clorox when we first locked down. But then I thought, once things,
但是，我喜欢香味，就像，我喜欢混合精油和香水。我喜欢那个。所以我想开一家蜡烛公司，然后我想，我们在家待了这么久，起初，当然，我们刚封锁时到处都是高乐氏的味道。但后来我想，一旦事情，
we didn't have to wipe out our packages, and all that stuff. I thought, why not have your home, like room spray, a counter spray, your dish soap, or your hand soap, and what smell like the way you'd want your, it's called beauty products for the home, essentially. And it's all recycled plastic,
我们不需要擦拭包裹，所有那些东西。我想，为什么不让你的家，比如房间喷雾、台面喷雾、洗洁精或洗手液，闻起来像你想要的那样，它本质上就是家居美容产品。而且全是回收塑料，
it's all, we got a chemist that does makeup. That's how it's approved for everything. So not, I'm not saying spray it in your face, like an atomizer, or what's it called? Toner. Spritzer. But if it got on your- Jason wants to see the carb count
全是，我们找了一位做化妆品的化学家。这就是它通过所有认证的原因。所以不是，我不是说像雾化器那样喷在脸上，或者叫什么？爽肤水。喷雾。但如果它沾到了你的——杰森想看碳水化合物含量
before he sprays that on his face. Yeah, will it make me puffy if I spray it on my face? Do not do that, but it's safe for everything. And it smells so good. And there's four scents. You could basically have one scent that goes through your whole house, whether it be your dishwashing soap,
在他把它喷在脸上之前。是的，如果我把它喷在脸上会让我浮肿吗？不要那样做，但它对所有东西都是安全的。而且闻起来太棒了。有四种香味。你基本上可以让一种香味贯穿你的整个房子，无论是你的洗洁精，
your hand soap, your room spray. No, but what if you want to mix, you don't want one scent, you want to mix it up. Yeah, there's four scents, but each scent goes through all the product lines. So you may want to wash your dishes with rose, and you may want your room to have a candle that is my signature scent,
你的洗手液，你的房间喷雾。不，但如果你想混合呢，你不想只有一种香味，你想混合一下。是的，有四种香味，但每种香味都贯穿所有产品线。所以你可能想用玫瑰味洗碗，你可能想让你的房间里有一支蜡烛，那是我的签名香味，
which I think smells incredible. It's kind of smoky slash. I love that idea. Do you see yourself expanding because you do love design and architecture and all that stuff? Do you see yourself getting and expanding that into doing like home furnishings and stuff like that?
我觉得闻起来不可思议。它有点烟熏味，斜杠。我喜欢那个主意。你看到自己扩展了吗，因为你确实喜欢设计和建筑以及所有那些东西？你看到自己进入并扩展到做家居装饰之类的东西了吗？
Like I think that you would put it this way. If you had a line of stuff, I'd be like, well, I'm going to do what Courtney does. I mean, anything can happen because once you have a company called Home Court, you could do anything. I mean, we could expand to whether it's laundry pods to, I mean, that would be great.
就像我觉得你会这样说。如果你有一系列产品，我会说，好吧，我要做考特尼做的事。我是说，任何事情都可能发生，因为一旦你拥有了一家叫Home Court的公司，你就可以做任何事。我是说，我们可以扩展到洗衣凝珠，我是说，那会很棒。
I love to make sheets because I'm obsessed with sheets. Well, Sean needs a new set. Yeah, he sure does. I don't sheet myself, get it? So Courtney, what's on tap for you for the rest of the day? What's your life like right now? What do you do?
我喜欢做床单，因为我痴迷于床单。好吧，肖恩需要一套新的。是的，他确实需要。我不会弄脏自己，懂吗？所以考特尼，你今天剩下的时间有什么安排？你现在的生活是什么样的？你做什么？
Tell them you're busy. Tell them you're busy. The D to D, the D to D. All right, I'm going to go into town and box. I'm going to, I'm going to go to a dermatologist because I had this weird thing on top of my head and it was like a little- It could be a butterfly, it could be a butterfly.
告诉他们你很忙。告诉他们你很忙。日常，日常。好吧，我要进城去拳击。我要，我要去看皮肤科医生，因为我头顶上有个奇怪的东西，它像个小——它可能是只马蝇，可能是只马蝇。
Oh, shit. I better check that. And then I'm going to go with Amanda, by the way. Yeah, yeah. I'm going to go, well, I'm going to go like, oh, I'm going to go to the gym equipment place first because I want to buy some home gym equipment. You've got a great home gym.
哦，该死。我最好检查一下。然后我要和阿曼达一起去，顺便说一句。是的，是的。我要去，好吧，我要去，哦，我要先去健身器材店，因为我想买一些家庭健身器材。你有一个很棒的家庭健身房。
You're adding to it? Yeah, you've got so much more. I want like a machine that can do things. I need to- Gotcha. Now, you know, Will's, Will Box is with the fight camp. I do. Oh, you do?
你在增加设备？是的，你还有更多。我想要一台能做各种事情的机器。我需要——明白了。现在，你知道，威尔和Fight Camp一起拳击。我知道。哦，你真的吗？
Every day. Get one of those fight camp things in your gym. You don't have to drive into the city to box. Courtney, it has been- What's a fight camp? It's been a game changer. Our buddy, we have a friend of the show is a, who sometimes writes in questions,
每天。在你的健身房里弄一个那种Fight Camp的东西。你不需要开车进城去拳击。考特尼，这已经——什么是Fight Camp？这已经改变了游戏规则。我们的伙伴，我们有一位节目之友，有时会写信提问，
a JT out of New York. And he's got a- Justin T. He's sleeve challenged. Let's just say that. He's sleeve challenged. Yeah, poor guy. And he turned me on to this thing fight camp
来自纽约的JT。他有一个——贾斯汀·T。他袖子受限。我们就这么说吧。他袖子受限。是的，可怜的家伙。他大约一年前向我推荐了这个Fight Camp
about a year ago. No, six months ago. And it's so good. And it's like a, you know, there's like a whole program. You can do it like on your laptop or your thing. And then you have a heavy bag and you do the, you know, I did eight rounds this morning. When do they tell you to expect results?
不，六个月前。它太棒了。它就像一个，你知道，有一个完整的程序。你可以在你的笔记本电脑或你的设备上做。然后你有一个重沙袋，你做那个，你知道，我今天早上做了八轮。他们什么时候让你期待结果？
Well- We're all dying. Oh boy. No, seriously, Court, you could go over to Will's place. You guys could do boxing sessions together. You guys could do like a little ring. Come look at my setup. It's so good.
好吧——我们都快死了。天哪。不，说真的，考特，你可以去威尔那里。你们可以一起做拳击训练。你们可以像弄个小拳击台。来看看我的设置。太棒了。
Come with Amanda. Well, I'm not, I'm going to be playing golf today with our friends from Callaway. Oh yeah. What's Callaway? Now these people from Callaway, thank you, Callaway. They are, they're very generous. Is that a golf course?
带上阿曼达。好吧，我不是，我今天要去和我们卡拉威的朋友打高尔夫球。哦，是的。什么是卡拉威？现在这些人来自卡拉威，谢谢，卡拉威。他们，他们非常慷慨。那是一个高尔夫球场吗？
It's a golf company. Hashtag rogue. The new stuff is pretty good. And they sent us some new stuff and it's really nice. And we didn't even, this is not a paid thing. We just, they just sent us some golf gloves. Hey, let me ask you something. Sean doesn't want to come play.
那是一家高尔夫公司。标签Rogue。新产品相当不错。他们给我们寄了一些新东西，真的很好。我们甚至没有，这不是付费推广。我们只是，他们只是给我们寄了一些高尔夫手套。嘿，让我问你一件事。肖恩不想来玩。
Do you, do you have to buy your own golf balls or do they give them to you when you go? They are nice enough to give us some golf balls. Okay. They give us golf balls too. But generally a person you go and you buy golf balls. Yeah. Cause I gave you some golf balls, Jay, for Christmas.
你，你必须自己买高尔夫球吗，还是你去的时候他们会给你？他们足够好，会给我们一些高尔夫球。好的。他们也给我们高尔夫球。但通常一个人去买高尔夫球。是的。因为我圣诞节给了你一些高尔夫球，杰。
I just didn't know. Yeah, no, I have those. Yeah. Yeah. That's a weird way to say thanks. Yeah. I have those. What a funny, what a funny twist on thank you.
我只是不知道。是的，不，我有那些。是的。是的。那是一种奇怪的感谢方式。是的。我有那些。多么有趣的，多么有趣的感谢转折。
Wait, so Courtney. And it's a funny twist. So Courtney, you're going to go, you're going to go and do what I love about it is talking about self care. You're going to do it. You're going to do workout. You're going to get some gym equipment.
等等，所以考特尼。这是一个有趣的转折。所以考特尼，你要去，你要去，我喜欢的是谈论自我保健。你要去做。你要去锻炼。你要去买一些健身器材。
You're going to get, you're going to get a dermatologist like. And then I'm going to hang out with Jason's wife. I mean, what are you doing with my wife? And is it going to benefit me at all? Are you guys shopping for me? Well, she's going to get some food. So maybe she'll bring it home. That's helpful.
你要去，你要去看皮肤科医生。然后我要和杰森的妻子一起玩。我是说，你和我妻子在做什么？这对我有任何好处吗？你们在为我购物吗？好吧，她要去买些食物。所以也许她会带回家。那很有帮助。
But we're going to go visit Nicole. Okay. Nicole Levant. Yeah. And you guys are going to go buy some yummy food. Jason, oh, you guys are going to have some yummy cardboard. Can't wait gluten-free or something to call it. There's a hummus bread on there.
但我们要去拜访妮可。好的。妮可·勒凡特。是的，你们要去买些美味的食物。杰森，哦，你们要去吃些美味的纸板。等不及无麸质之类的东西了。上面有鹰嘴豆泥面包。
By the way, I like gluten-free bread more than regular bread. It's chewier. It has better texture with gluten-free. Thank you for that. Incredible. I'm gluten-free. What kind of bread do you use? Anything gluten-free.
顺便说一句，我喜欢无麸质面包胜过普通面包。它更有嚼劲。无麸质的质地更好。谢谢你的分享。不可思议。我是无麸质的。你用什么面包？任何无麸质的。
Gluten-free pizza is real yummy, too. Oh, yeah. Oh, you've convinced yourself that's good, too. Yeah. Have you guys tried quinoa? This is cool. Have you tried regular just everyday food? Jason, no, I'm trying to hit 100, Sean.
无麸质披萨也很好吃。哦，是的。哦，你也说服自己那个也很好吃。是的。你们试过藜麦吗？这很酷。你们试过普通的日常食物吗？杰森，不，我正试图达到100岁，肖恩。
I want to get to 100. I'm not happy with 65. So Courtney, anyway, gosh, I mean, we could just keep going forever. We could hang, I didn't even realize that we're over the time. We've taken up way too much of your time. Yeah. We just love talking.
我想活到100岁。我对65岁不满意。所以考特尼，总之，天哪，我是说，我们可以永远聊下去。我们可以待着，我甚至没意识到我们超时了。我们占用了你太多时间了。是的。我们只是喜欢聊天。
What do you have a tea time, Will? You got to get out to the range? No, I actually don't, not yet. And we- But Courtney does. She does. We love talking to you. Spending time with you is just the best.
威尔，你有开球时间吗？你得去练习场吗？不，我其实没有，还没。而且我们——但考特尼有。她有。我们喜欢和你聊天。和你在一起度过时光真是太棒了。
You're such an awesome person as we, I'm going to end the same way that we started. So thanks for coming and hanging with us. Yeah. Thank you. I don't get to see you enough these days. So I miss hanging out. I don't feel like we did an episode today.
你是一个如此棒的人，正如我们，我要以我们开始的方式结束。所以谢谢你来和我们一起玩。是的。谢谢。这些天我见你的次数不够多。所以我很怀念在一起玩。我觉得我们今天没做一期节目。
That just feels like just normal chat because we're all so close, which I guess means it's great. Yeah. Thanks, guys. I'm so glad to be on the show. I really, all three of you, looking at your, just like friends. Thank you, honey.
那感觉就像正常的聊天，因为我们都太亲近了，我想这意味着这很棒。是的。谢谢，伙计们。我很高兴能上这个节目。我真的，你们三个，看着你们，就像朋友一样。谢谢，亲爱的。
Yeah, well, good luck. Listen, good luck with your show. Very, very looking forward to it. I can't wait to watch it. Tell us the date again when it starts on- March the 6th. March the 6th. March the 6th.
是的，好吧，祝你好运。听着，祝你的节目好运。非常，非常期待它。我迫不及待想看了。再告诉我们一次它开始的日期——3月6日。3月6日。3月6日。
And the line came out on January 26th. Home court. And I want a free dozen candles. If you don't go and buy a home court, no, no, no, not free, she's starting a business. All right. Go buy a dozen candles. Go get a friend's rate.
产品线是1月26日出来的。Home Court。如果你们不去买Home Court，我就要一打免费蜡烛，不，不，不，不是免费的，她在创业。好吧。去买一打蜡烛。去拿个朋友价。
Thank you, Courtney. We love you. Thanks, Courtney. Love you, honey. Courtney, love you. Bye, sweetie. Bye, Courtney. Just slam it, slam it.
谢谢，考特尼。我们爱你。谢谢，考特尼。爱你，亲爱的。考特尼，爱你。再见，甜心。再见，考特尼。直接关掉，关掉。
Slam the laptop. Slam it. Yeah, yeah. How great is Courtney? And I know that I sort of started and ended the same way, but she's such a great person. Always made me feel warm and welcome anytime I see her or anytime I was over at her house, yeah.
关上笔记本电脑。关掉它。是的，是的。考特尼有多棒？我知道我开始和结束的方式差不多，但她真是个很棒的人。无论我什么时候见到她，或者什么时候去她家，她总是让我感到温暖和受欢迎，是的。
Really funny, really sweet. Really cool and very considerate. Not affected by her success or from... At all. She is of the arts. At all. Yeah, I love it. Yeah, I don't have anything nice to say.
非常有趣，非常甜美。非常酷，非常体贴。一点也没有受到她成功的影响……一点也没有。她是艺术中人。一点也没有。是的，我喜欢。是的，我没什么好话可说。
Huh. That's funny, because she entertains you a lot. Like you go and stay at her house quite often. Listen, she is a single mom that has an incredible daughter and is incredibly, they're both so happy and fulfilled in their life. They've got an incredible group of friends around them. It's in such a sort of star-filled sort of world
哈。那很有趣，因为她让你很开心。比如你经常去她家住。听着，她是一位单身母亲，有一个不可思议的女儿，而且非常，她们俩在生活中都非常快乐和满足。她们周围有一群不可思议的朋友。这在一个充满明星的世界里
that brings all of its sort of complexities and challenges and all of that garbage. Sheila's a very normal life, which is great. Yeah, she leads a deserved, charmed life. You know what it's also funny? Dax and I used to always joke about this, that we joke like the greatest compliment that we'd be like sort of foe humbled by
带来了各种复杂性和挑战以及所有那些垃圾。希拉过着非常正常的生活，这很棒。是的，她过着应得的、迷人的生活。你知道还有什么有趣的吗？达克斯和我过去总是拿这个开玩笑，我们开玩笑说，我们会被那种虚假的谦逊所折服，
as if somebody said like, he's a great guy and he's just an incredible friend. What a friend. We'd be like, oh, like I have this sort of false modesty. Like, oh, thank you. Thank you. But she is the epitome of that. Yeah, for sure.
就好像有人说，他是个好人，是个不可思议的朋友。多好的朋友。我们会说，哦，我有这种虚假的谦逊。比如，哦，谢谢。谢谢。但她就是那种人的缩影。是的，当然。
She is such a great friend to so many people. And she's kind of one of those people that if anybody's going through anything, you're not surprised when they go like, I called Courtney. You're like, yeah, of course. Of course you called Courtney. She's gonna give you good advice and she's gonna listen and she's gonna be kind and thoughtful
她是这么多人的好朋友。她是那种如果有人经历什么事，你不会感到惊讶的人，当他们说，我给考特尼打了电话。你会说，是的，当然。当然你给考特尼打了电话。她会给你好的建议，她会倾听，她会善良、体贴
and loving and warm. She's gonna be there for you. Yeah, yeah, because I have a friend, he's like, my job's a joke, I'm broke. My love life's DOA. I feel like I'm always stuck in second gear when it hasn't been my day, my week, my month, or even my year.
充满爱心和温暖。她会为你而在。是的，是的，因为我有个朋友，他说，我的工作是个笑话，我破产了。我的爱情生活死气沉沉。我觉得我总是卡在二档，这不是我的日子，我的周，我的月，甚至我的年。
Wait, are those the lyrics to the, come on. Oh, hey, Jason, I just got a text from 1994. Wait a second, is that truly the lyrics of the song? Yes, that's the song of different friends. Good God. Don't you think they should bring the whole cast back, not call it, not a reboot of friends, call it enemies, right, so they've gotten older
等等，那是歌词吗，拜托。哦，嘿，杰森，我刚收到一条1994年的短信。等等，那真的是那首歌的歌词吗？是的，那是不同朋友的歌。天哪。你不觉得他们应该把整个剧组带回来，不叫它，不是《老友记》的重启，叫它《敌人》，对吧，所以他们变老了
and now they're just assholes to each other. Don't you think that would be funny? Yeah. No. Enemies, no. Terrible idea. Yeah, but pitch it around town and see what you get. You know what I wanna say to you?
现在他们只是互相混蛋。你不觉得那会很有趣吗？是的。不。《敌人》，不。糟糕的主意。是的，但在城里推销一下，看看你会得到什么。你知道我想对你说什么吗？
What's that? Bye. Oh. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted
那是什么？再见。哦。聪明。少。聪明。少。SmartLess是100%有机的，由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴巴科手工制作。聪明。少。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus提前且无广告收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Less. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barbaco制作。SmartLess。我们的下一集将在下周发布，您可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就通过Amazon Music抢先收听，也可以通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery App中的Wondery Plus抢先收听且无广告。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。